Look at this Darkiplier-ass thing.
(PSA for Markiplier fans: PLEASE STOP COMMENTING IN THE CAPTIONS. IT IS FOR HEARING IMPAIRED PEOPLE. SAVE YOUR COMMENTS FOR THE COMMENT SECTION PLEASE!)
Look at- look at this thing. Look at that.
It's like Selene straight out of it.
Tsk, tsk, tsk.
I'm watching you. I'm watching you! I'm watching you! I'm watching you.
Welcome back to another episode of "SCP Containment Breach".
For some reason Unity would not work, so I am going to go back into this--
AH-- And we are gonna immediately run away from-- Larry.
I'm gonna immediately go.
Ok, I'm just gonna gun it thought the gas 'cause I know there's gas..
And I'm just gonna run; and that is all there is to it.
[Incredible amount of stuttering]
And I'm gonna go.
So we just gotta go.
We have to hit the button (x3).
We gotta to hit the button to get through it.
And then we are gonna get through it and lead him through the Tesla gate-- AND WE GO!
Go! I got it. I hit it!
Ah-- MY EYES, MY EYES!
MY EYES!
Okay. I should probably keep going because I doubt that he's gonna be--
He's probably going to be right behind me.
Oh, God.
Oh God. Oh God. Oh God. Oh God. Oh God. Oh God. Oh God.
I need the mask so I can run infinitely.
Uh, go!
Okay, he is right behind me.
He is definitely right behind me.
Okay.
Hai, ay, ay.
Okay, he is definitely--
Okay. Trigger it.
And go!
Okay, lets see if this gets him!
Oh. Okay. Here we go. Here we go
Come on. Come on. Come on, you-- you--
Oh!
OH
OH! OH!
Oh, get dicked!
Oh. Get straight up DICKED!
Oh, get all that DICK!
Oh, you got DICKED!
Oh, you got dicked..
Oh, yeah. Get dicked..
Okay. Well, are you right outside the door?
Better not be right outside the door.
Okay. I'm gonna take the gas mask off so that I can actually see shit.
Okay.
So!
There's a way thought the middle.
Though there.
I dont remember what was over here.
What was in the way here?
Anything important?
Or nothing important at all?
Oh! That's where that goes. Okay, lets not go back just yet. Let's go around the other loop just to make sure we cover all of our bases.
And to make sure that they do, in fact, belong to us.
And that we can contin-- [Mark hears Chewbacca-like sounds]
Chewbacca, is that you again?
[Imitates Chewbacca]
Uh, I don't know what that is.
Okay, let me check this again.
Also I don't know why I have the badge.
I probably don't need it.
OHHH.
Ohhh..
Okay.
I don't remember these.
But okay. I probably have a high enough badge to-- Yeaahh.
Okay.
Close it behind me.
So, this is SCP 714. I don't remember what that one is.
Oh, it's the ring! Okay, I can use this ring to my advantage if I'm smart about this.
Put this in here..
I don't have the burnt note, but I remember 7414 was the code on the note.
I just don't know if that changes from time to time.
I think I remem--
Ew.
Okay, so. The thing about this is--
It causes you to go slow. Be sluggish, reduce mental capacity. But it is a shield.
It is a shield versus some kind of chemical,
or poison, or like..
Memetic effect.
Which is something the SCP Foundation really loves.
The love their memes!
They do love their memes, indeed, they do.
So I'm gonna drop the leaflet.
Ah, shit.
I'm gonna put this in here.
I'm gonna take it.
I'm not gonna put it on, but just in case I might need something for that.
I'm gonna.. Keep that.
Okay.
Whoa...
Ohhhh... Yeah...
Wait...
Wait, wha?
Wait.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, I don't know what this is.
Wait.
Okay, hang on. I think I can drop a battery.
I don't need the origami anyway.
[Mark gasps]
Wait, no. That's the locket!
Uh-oh then. Oh, shit!
Okay. Alright.
Resistance to disease and toxins increases by 500% compared to accepted LD50 or death-rate.
After a total of 10 minutes of exposure...
And 100--
1000% affected.
After 15 minutes, muscles systems begin to-- blah-- increasing strength and pain tolerance by 200-300%
Other systems continue to optimize.
Class D personnel exposed to the device for over a hour total began mutating into shapeless mass of tissue.
The conversion time accelerate with continued exposure to SCP 427.
Mm...
Right. Okay.
Weird.
So it cures the common cold in about two to four minutes.
But if you- the longer you have it, the more it morphs you into something horrible.
So someone took it.
It's not here, so someone must've been REALLY desperate if they needed that.
And then I'm pretty sure that they turned into something real bad.
Okay. So that's good to know I guess.
Anybody here?
Anybody? No? Okay.
Alright.
What is over here?
Man...
I remember that- in these places, there used to be just like places holding empty stuff.
Okay, that one's bad. I know this is the book of diseases, I don't want to read that because every single one I read I will get.
So that's bad. Don't pick that up.
This is- I don't know what this is. What is this?
What is this?
Oh. The key!
[Mark gasps]
OOOOHHHH!
I'll leave you an origami. I'll take the key.
We do need the key.
Okay. So, the key is to a door that leads to that dimension, where that animation was made from with that sweet little thing that didn't want to kill me.
So that's to the mystery door.
So, we got the key.
We got a lot of shit.
I don't need this anymore, I'm gonna drop that.
Anything on the radio?
[Turns on and shifts through channels]
[Alarm briefly makes a noise]
Wait. What was-
Didn't- Didn't- Something just appeared on my screen.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Did you guys see that?
Wait, no. Tell me I'm not crazy.
Wasn't there some text right in the middle of the screen?
I swear I saw something!
Okay. Alright. I'm trusting you that I'm just crazy on that one.
Okay.
Shit.
Alright. Anyway.
Let's keep going. Oh, It's the hallway of repeating. Am I wrong?
It's the repeating hallway.
Yeah it is.
Oh, a cup.
I think I need the cup for something.
No, not the card. I need the cup.
The cup for the- Um..
The thing.
Okay, so this is just the repeating hallway.
As you repeat in it, it gets weirder and weirder right?
Recursive Spacial Phenomenon.
Yeah.
Okay. So what I'm gonna do is, I'm actually gonna go save because I'm pretty sure the deeper you go into it eventually... It gets down where it kills you?
Which is probably not good.
If I had just to guess about the whole death thing, probably not good.
Eeee.
Where am I going?
Where am I?
Okay. We're almost at the end of where THIS allows me to go.
So lets peek-a-boo in here.
SHIT
Welp, now I'm infected by that thing but I think there's a monitor in here.
It's harmless, over-
ARRGGHHH
I wasn't.
Now I am.
Okay. Well I got the creepy crawlie on me now.
That's good.
Okay. I hope that they didn't change that to be lethal 'cause that would be fun..
Okay. There's that.
That.
Yeah.
Whatever.
Fuck that thing.
Fuck that thing real hard.
I don't think there's actually any way to contain that thing, so..
[Sound of a metal door opening]
AH!
Ahhhh- I got an achievement. I saw it.
Okay, alright,
Okay, alright.
I saw that.
Did I- I usually close my doors behind me.
I thought I closed that one.
Okay.
Well, what do we got in here?
It's the music doodle-loo?
Yeah, that's the music.
But I don't need to go in there.
Oooooo.
[Mark gasps]
Waaait a minute..
Wait.
They had this in the Unity version.
Did they always have it in this version too?
Ohhh...
I think I've done this.
I think I've done this. This is ringing a bell. But I..
Now I'm not a 100% sure.
Yeah, no.
Yeah, it was.
Okay.
So...
I'm not sure if it's like- I'm not gonna save, just in case. 'Cause I know that it's like..
The longer you- Ooo...
What the fuck.
The longer you watch, the badder it gets for you.
Yeah it gets bad. So I- I think it might be too late.
I'm not sure.
Oh, boy..
Yeah...
I'm not gonna gonna save.
I'm NOT gonna save.
I think I've-
Yeah I've seen-
Yeah I've seen that. No, this wasn't in the unity version
Was it?
No it wasn't.
Mayb- I dunno!
But it ain't good.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
UH-OH
UH-OHH
WHOA-
UM- UH.
UHHHHHH.
Yeah, the story behind this is pretty scary.
Like this- Oh yeah, they're aggressive. Oh yeah, I know.
Yeah, you see a lady die, then I die.
Yep, no. This is death incoming. So..
But I'm just gonna show you guys just to remin-
Oh, shit.
Hey! I can go in?!
Oh hell yeah, I can go in!
Hey-- UH-OH.
Um, uh..
Uhhhh...
Oh..
AH, OW!
Ow!
Uh..
Ay, ay, ay..
OW!
Why are you doing that to the base of my neck?
OW.
Huh, I seem to be blee- OW..
[Mark stutters]
Mysteriously, I'm bleeding from-
OW.
Listen. Listen.
OOWW!
List- Listen! Listen!
Listen...
Listen.
Lisstennn...
No need for that- Okay now we're back here but that's okay.
La-dee-dee-dee-da-da.
Alright. So that just a dead end. I don't think that there was anything of value to get out of that.
I think that was just a- -
DOOR CLOSE-
But let me check down here to see if there's anything of value down here.
I don't think there is, but just in case let me look.
[Mark starts humming]
Da- doo- doo- da- doo- doo..
Oo, what the fuck? They didn't have controls here-
AHH.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO
Hoist? Host! Hoist! Hoist.
Door!
Door, get the door!
Get the door!
Okay.
[Mark makes weird sounds]
Waluigi in there just- [Imitates Waluigi's laugh].
Hate that thing.
I think I got about everything in here! So, I guess I hate everything in-
Whoa.
HEY WHOA! WHOA! WHOA! HEY! WHOA! OKAY WAIT NO! NO! DON'T! HEY, WAIT.
OOHHH, BOYY.
WAIT. WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN HERE
WHY ARE WE LOADING?
WHY'D WE LOAD?
DON'T LOAD. STOP LOADS!
DON'T LOAD. What is this? Surveillance room?!? What is that?
HUH?!
Okay.
Hold on to your tits.
Just for a second.
What is surveillance room?
I'm in.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's just close this up.
Close that up.
Okay. Alright.
Oohhh... I- I remember this. Okay, I remember this surveillance room.
It's just- Is there something? Okay it's locked.
Oh, my mouse is getting all fucky again!
Mouse is getting all fucky..
I don't know why..
Wait there was something- Wait.
Something's telling me bad stuff.
Something's telling me- Uh.. Big no-no on this.
Something's- Uh, I'm getting big no-no things in my brain.
I'm getting big no-no. Big no-no's in my-
I'm getting big no-no's in my head.
Big no-no's in my head!
BIG NO-NO'S IN MY HEAD!
BIG! NO! NO'S! IN! MY! HEAD
Hi.
I've got big no-no's in my head.
Uh- Well let's see- We can talk about this.
We can talk about this.
Oh God!
He's smart.
[Mark whispers]
He's learning...
Hello! AH!
Doctor! No.
No need for that, doccy.
Listen, doc.
Listen.
Listen, you can just stay here-
Okay. Never mind then.
I'll go this a-way.
AH! There's something behind me!
I'm gonna RUN!
I'm gonna run!
Running, running, quickly, fastly now.
Okay. Is he still behind me?
I don't know.
Is there something else behind me?!
I don't know!
I didn't get to unlock the Containment Zone, which is what I was supposed to do but I was in too much of a panic!
Is he still coming for me?
049.
He's still on the radar.
Do you think- wait. Do you think..
Wait.. Do you think that it would?
Do you think it might?
[Gasp]
He's-
He's somewhere.
Wait. Okay, I'm gonna take this off and put on the ring.
Oh..
Okay..
I'm gonna go back to where he was.
I got the ring on.
Hey, buddy. Listen.
Hey, touch me!
SCP 049: Stop resisting. I may have to kill you.
MARK: AH, WHOA, WAIT, WHOA. WHOA.
Whoa, hey. Listen.
Okay. Alright. It worked for a bit.
Just apparently not for long.
Ah...
Okay.
I'm not sure if it just worked for a bit.
But I think that- I think that it did. I think that it did.
Because it was like- He said stop resisting.
Where, as ordinarily, as soon as he touches you, you're done-zo.
Right?
Yeeeaaaah.
Okay, that was cool. Okay.
We gotta go back up in there.
And now this time when we go back up in there, I'm actually gonna--
Turn- Oh yeah, I'm here.
Okay.
I'm actually gonna turn off the shit.
So I'm not gonna go there because I don't need to go there.
Let's just go this way.
I know that Mr. Billy Man is gonna be--
[Zap]
Gonna be over here.
For some reason, I didn't close this GODDAMN DOOR.
Oh, yeah. I was looking for the loop-ty loop so I can get the Recursive Dimension!
Uh-oh.
Shit.
Alright. Well, close that.
Oh, yeah.
That's right.
"Door appears to be locked." Oh yeah. You're supposed to go this way.
Oh, shi-
AH, THE FUCKING-
Ah.. God, the fucking-
God, the fucking-
Larry..
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, so what I'm gonna do-
-is I'm gonna brute force this bad boy-
-and I'm just gonna keep running.
Here we go.
Go.
Oh! Saw that.
Oo!
Yup.
Okay, that's-
That's different. Okay, big blood stain on the ground. I remember that.
I'm just gonna go in this for a long time.
Oh, shit. Wait. Whoa. Whoa.
Was that-
[Mutters]
Okay, that's fine...
Listening's fine.
It's fine.
I've never actually read the Wiki on this one.
Well, I actually don't know what the true story was-
Wha..
OH!
Yeah, there's that body I was tellin' you about.
Okay. Hey, Mr. Hole in the Head.
Okay.
Alright.
You alright, buddy?
Wha-
'Kay. My vision is doing something when I look at that!
That's a little interesting!
Okay. Whatever.
Carrying on!
RADIO: To everyone still hearing this: We all have heard the professor during containment breaches of this magnitude.
During containment breaches of this magnitude..
[Voice becomes distorted]
During the containment breaches of this magnitude..
D̷̨̫̳̯̳̘̪̜̍̄̋̈́̇̕̚ͅṳ̴̖̗͇̓̎̓̚͜͠r̵͕̫͕̬͌̇̾̚͘ĭ̴͎̤̣͖͕̤͔͌͗̀̋͝ñ̷̛̛͚̠̮̱͎̬̮̲͉̂̔̆̓͌̇̍̕͝͝g̸͙̍̌̐͌͝ ̶͇̗͎̠̣͚͐͗̿̒t̸̨̧̙͎̝̟̖̠̝̠̦̦̫͚͕̏̆͑̒̒̅͗̋̇̀h̵̡̰͎̭̽e̶͓̘͓͖̼̼̗͍̓̈́ ̴̧͕̤̗̱̱͈̟̗̥̖̗̘̞̈̾́̈́̌͒͒̅̈́͗c̷̭͊̎̆́̔͛̇̐͑̈͠ơ̴̤͍͎͚̲̬̦̦̺̣̙̥͒̒͋̉͂̓̊̈̄͜n̸̺̜̖͙̙̔̾̿t̶͙̜̞̩͇̭̎͒͘a̶̢͚͙̯̖̗̱̾̃͌͒i̶͍͒̾̿̂̎͋ͅn̸̢̜̭̺̣͉̯͓̿̈̎̽͊̓̋̀͌͑̓̒͂̚m̸̧̘̰̯̗̜͇͖̙͖̼̍͂̉ẽ̸̱̻͖̗̞̟̞̙͎͚̓͒̕n̶̡̧̖̗̱̱̙̬̿͒͆͋̾͗̍͠t̸̡̲͚̙̼̲̬̯͎͎͈̎̍̑̌̒̈͗͐̕ ̷̢͚͛̔͗͂̐͐̔͐̇͒̌̽̒b̴̡̤͕̺̺͇̰͖̺̦͙͖̅͆͜͠ͅr̵̹̞̲̠̓e̸̛̘͌͗̆̉̎̽̈́̅́̇͝ą̴̞̖̯͕̥͔̜͔͔̯̍̎͊͑̎̀̃̚c̷͚̠̜̥͙̙̅̈́͜ͅh̶̼͓̯̓̎͑͐́͆ȩ̷͎͕̟̥̰̖̱̲̘͖̺͍̬̟͛̄̌̉́̅͊͗s̴̡̱̮͖̦͖̟̖̦͓̭̫̙̹̏̾̈́ ̵̢̡̻͉͕̙̺͎̫̺̘͈̤͌͗̅͐̏̒̑͌́ǫ̵̡̙̠̙͖̦̘̫̣̗̅́̆̄́̑̈́͐̈́̈́͘͝f̶̡̛̛͉͕͙͙̫̏́̂̍͊̍͐́̆̓͜͠͝ ̵̡̪̞̱͇̲͎͍̞̲̎͛̿̋͛̎̄̀̈́̐́̚͘͘t̶̥̞̥̝̝̰͓͚͎̗͒̓́̇͊͋̓́̑̃͒̓̑̚͜͠h̵̠̮̟̘͈͖̠͓͗̎͋̽̒͝i̷̲͓̭͔̯̱̒̏̏̌̃̽͌͆̈́͝͝s̵̡̘̹̠̟̖̗̰̜̬̪̪̻̈́̑͑̏͌͋͜͝͝ ̴̧̙̺̙̳̗͖͎͙̽͊̏̾̾̿͗͐̿͘͘͝m̴̢̥̭̝͙̮̖͍̯͔̩̥̀ã̸̡̢̫̹͇̮͈̫̑́̔͜g̷̢̛̞̥̲̥̩͖̳̹͓̹̝̱̪͐̽̊̈́̿̈́̆̾̐̈͑͝ñ̵͚̝͖͔̭̼͚̝̩̂̐̋͘͘͠͠ì̴̲͎̠͓̙͂̈͜t̴̨͕͕̘̝̥͔̱͇̹̯̠̲̀̔̉̄͐͛̋̈́͛̽̉̅͝͝͠ü̵͈̠̙̭̙͎̰͙̪͓̏͊̅̇̓̎͑͋d̷̝̊͗͐̂̿͆̓̈́̃͌͌̊͘͝ͅe̷̤͔̼̽.̵̨̘͈̓́̊.̷̑̿̂͋̑̂͒͝͠
RADIO: Hello? Is anyone out there?
....I don't know what-
...I don't-
...Oh god it's coming...
...Someone...
Please anyone...
...Please...
...Someone needs to broadcast this station at once...
Oh god what is that?
....What is that?...
That's better.
Okay. Whatever.
Alright. Well, back to running!
Well, that was a bizarre turn of events, but okay!
Back to me running!
I see that- That the Unity devs. wanna talk to me. I see it. I'm pleasantly ignoring it because I'm in the middle of something.
Can't you see I'm BUSY?
Alright, anything changed?
No...
OH!
WHAT? HI.
UH.
HM- WHA?
What?
The- uh.
Uh.
Uh...
Uh..
Um..
UH..
Okay..
Alright.
Oh.
WHOA. WHOA. THERE HE GOES.
There he is!
There's- There's our boy!
There's our boy!
Ah...
Well..
Um... Uh...
A little bizarre, but not too bizarre..
Okay. Alright. Nothing new.
I think I got to that point before, but I think someone told me...
After the fact that after this, there's even more. And I didn't get to that point.
So I just gotta keep going!
I'll just keep going!
Keep going!
A LITTLE MOOOORE.
TO THE LEEEFT.
Eh- Uh- Uh-
TO THE RIIIIIGHT.
Uh- YOU PUT YOUR RIGHT FOOT IN.
YOU- YOU PUT YOUR RIGHT FOOT OUT.
YOU- YOU PUT YOUR RIGHT FOOT IN.
A- AND THEN, I- I'M SURE YOU SHAKE IT ALL ABOUT.
Okay, what I'm gonna do..
Is that I'm gonna quickly- Hang on.
I'm gonna quickly look on the Wiki-
NOOOOO!
Okay
So..
A document..
Yeah..
There it is.
NO, MY MAP!
NO, FUCK YOU.
MY MAP!
MY- MY MAP!
NOOO!
NOT MY MAP!
AHHHH...
MY MAP!
WELL, THIS SHIT-
BLACK, WHITE, BLACK, WHITE, BLACK, WHITE.
GRAY.
I SEE THAT GRAY IN THERE.
AH, FUCK YOU, SHITBAG.
DICKHOLE!
AHH...
Where's my clipboard?
What did you do with my clipboard?
Did you steal that-
God dammit..
Is that it?
Is this it?
It says a random item can appea-
Aw, you dickbag!
That was it?
Ah, fuck.
You-
God dammit.
Well, that was it.
This note.
Fucking-
I- I think I got that, you fucking dickbag!
UGH!
I gotta reload my game because of you!
I gotta go-
I gotta go die ag-
I can't even look where I want through this-
UGH!
Fuck it.
Fuck.
Fuck you and fuck that!
Fuck you!
I'm just gonna go die and get touched!
I'm gonna get tooched and die!
I'm gonna get tooched and I'm gonna die!
Fuckin' asshole...
Piece of shit.
A buffet of dicks. Yeah, that's what we need.
That's what we need, a buffet.
You wasted my TIME.
Wasting my time, wasting my life.
You being a douche.
You being a big ol' douche.
OFF.
Ugh.
Alright, whatever. Just come o-
[Speaks gibberish]
Who's coming up the stairs? I ain't one to wait for a threat.
TOUCH.
OW.
Ow.
Owwww.
Alright, we're going back into it.
So that was a dick, dicken, dick waste of my time.
Dick.
He's a dick dicken.
Dick Dickerson.
WHA- WHAT?
FU-
WHA-
THAT- OH, YOU CORNER CAMPING PIECE OF SHIT!
Are you kidding me? You're gonna be by the corn- Oh..
Oh, hey.
How's it go? I can make this.
I can do this.
AHHH!
FUCK!
*Exhale
Alright.
Oh, he's not here?
Oh, I hear him.
Where is he?
Whatever.
Ugh, I hate those things.
Where is he?
He through here?
I'm closing this!
Close.
Uh oh.
Corner of my eye, you say?
Mm...
Alright, whatever.
Watch these maneuvers.
I can totally beat the snot...
Out of any STUPID SCP...
That thinks they's smarter than me!
And they's ain't.
They's ain't. That's fo' damn sho'.
Alright.
Either way, I needed to do this because I needed to lift the lockdown on this area.
So.
Lift lockdown.
And then you...
I bet you can actually see him walking in, right?
That's the whole deal, right?
Oh, shit.
Oh yeah. There he is.
Hi, buddy!
Hey, buddy. Hey, buddy. Hey.
Alright, I'm gonna save real quick.
No. Can't save? Okay. That's probably for the best though.
Hey, buddy. Hey, buddy. How about a hi?
You can't see me, right?
There's no way that you can-
OH, SHIT.
He sees me.
Alright, I'm out of here.
You get-
You get..
Have fun.
You get have fun. You have fun with-
Oo, shit.
You get- Oh God.
Well, Okay I don't need to run so its fine.
He's pretty slow.
Okay so the- if this is true then this should open for me,
Right?
HEY... I did, I did. Okay I did
Oh, shit... What a code?
What do you mean a code?
Since when did I need a code?
Oh, shit
Is there like one...
Ohhh, is there like a code on any of these?
Ahh, shit.
I guess I could get..
Tooched by Larry and try to go through that way...
But I REALLY don't want to.
(Mark laughing)
Ehhh... ha ha hehhh
Ahhh... that's good shit.
That's good shit.
That's good shit right there.
That's...
That's good shit.
Eh That's good shit.
Funny, funny.
Okay, so.
Shit
Okay there's another...
Oh wait maybe that's just cause that one is... -door opens-
Maybe its cause that one's not working- AHH No, no -door close-
NOT GONNA EAR ME! -door opens-
You're not gonna...
Oh let me through -door closes-
(Exhale)
Not gonna ear me again. Not this time.
So I gotta go back the other way,
which means I gonna run into the doctor again.
But I can get around that.
That was too close.
But I haven't saved.
So that's a- That's another conundrum.
(Whispers) Okay.
While I'm running from him
(049: There's no need to hide, I'm here to help)
Okay there he is.
I can't. Alright. Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try to get him- Um,
I'm gonna get around him in this area
I'm gonna put on the ring AND the mask
I think both of those should allow me to run enough
(dog barks?)
Where is he?
No,no it doesn't. Okay.
(049: I am the cure.)
Oh shit, okay. Well at least I have-
Least I have the ring so if Iget around him...
(frustrated) Just get around him, get around him,
get around him.
There we go. Okay, oh shit. Oh shit.
Faster please! Faster would be great!
Faster would be great!
Little faster. Okay, I'm gonna take the ring off...
Ohhh shit. Move, move!
No, put on the mask! Maybe?!
Uhhhh run! There we go. Okay.
OH WHY?? IF IT ISN'T JUST FUCK MARK IN THE BUTTHOLE DAY.
Alright, I'm gonna go save
I'm gonna go save and there's nothing
that you can about it.
None that- oh shit. Here we go.
It's your demise Mr. Larry Man
Come at me, Bitch Boi!
Oh fuck. Why. That's not right.
Wait. No.
Ah- Ah Shit!
Where the fuck?
Ohhh! Mr. Bitch Tits come back
over here Huh? (mocks 106)
There he is.
Oh.
Ugh.
Gonna save. Just gonna save.
That's all I wanna do.
Just gonna save...
Saving...
Saved.
(Exhales then shakes head)
Okay. Alright.
Okay.
Whoo. Okay.
We're good. Everything's fine.
We're all kinds of good.
Yeeaahh. Okay.
We're spicy.
Oohh shiit.
What you gonna do? C'mon. Come at me.
C'mon.
You think that's it? Huh? Come at me.
(While mocking 173) Come even closer...
Come closer!
Oh cousin let's go bowling!
Come clooseerr...
Alright there we go shitdicks. Alright.